[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm caboose T here
and apples back at it again there is a
new color for the iPhone eight red and
so of course we're here with our first
look and our first impressions in our
unboxing of the new red iPhone and it's
a little bit different from last year so
the product red iPhone tradition that
started last year continues this year of
course we have more iPhones than normal
we have the 10 to 8 and the 8 plus but
this red is only for the 8 and the 8
plus but what's really new this time is
Apple actually listen to their customers
and this iPhone looks a little bit
different so let's hop right in so the
unboxing experience is gonna be the same
as any other iPhone 8 or 8 plus but of
course now you have the red box here
with a red text on a red apple logo and
it's the 256 gig 8 plus just for the
record you take a look at it it's the
same accessories in the Box the same
order of everything and of course now
you get the pamphlet if you purchase any
product red item from Apple if you
didn't know donates a portion of what
you spend to support HIV and AIDS
programs and research for them now I
don't know what portion exactly that is
but it's for sure going to a good cause
but then after the paperwork you get
that red iPhone in all its glory
and right off the bat you can see is
really really red it's a different red
from last year which was that anodized
matte red and aluminum finish this is
under glass now as the iPhone eight and
eight plus R so it's more of like this
Ferrari red or ruby or candy red and I
can't even explain to you exactly how
red this is the camera will have to do
it justice and then of course you flip
it over and you'll see that they did in
fact listen to us a lot of the big
complaints with last year's red iPhone
if we had any where that it had a white
front this year it's a straight up red
and black mkbhd Edition iPhone eight we
all want it so super red back all black
front there's no other Apple device like
this right on black I really really like
the look of it the more I look at it
it's really hard to capture in photos I
was trying to share them on Instagram
and Twitter but it's difficult this is a
seriously red phone now seeing what
they've done with this I really want an
iPhone 10 in this red also I brought it
up they wouldn't say if they would do it
or not but obviously it's the same glass
that's on the back of the iPhone 8 and
the iPhone 10 so I would love to see a
red iPhone 10 maybe sometime soon but
anyway all the way around the edges you
have your matching red anodized aluminum
still which is kind of a nice contrast
with the black front and then of course
the fingerprint reader touch ID and the
display everything else the internals
it's the exact same phone as all the
other iPhone eights just with different
colors and that's basically it
all we're doing is admiring a new color
here should you buy it maybe I mean as
beautiful as it is you got to think you
know it's six months into the Apple
product cycle there's gonna be a new
iPhone like iPhone 9 within like six
months like clockwork so if you're gonna
upgrade anyway go for it
but you got to know what's just around
the corner or maybe let's say you're
happy with your phone right now and you
don't want to spend a ton of money but
you still want a little bit of red in
your life if that guy you can of course
grab a skin for the iPhone which will
make it look a bit more red it's not
exactly the same as this Ferrari red
iPhone but of course the advantage is
you can make any phone look this way so
iPhone 10 for example you can turn red
which Apple didn't do yet so that's out
there I'll link to it below but bottom
line is we're just looking at a
mid-cycle refresh of a really cool new
color for the iPhone that goes to a good
cause
and I'm not mad at all about this but
anyway this is your first look feel free
to share this video with anyone who you
think might be interested in this super
bright red iPhone it's on sale now it's
on their site and I think it'll be in
stores in a couple of days officially
but let me know if you'd cop this let me
know if this speaks to you the way it
does to me either way quick video just
want to share this thanks for watching
talk to you the next one pace